This is an example of a suspension bridge,
and this is a capable state of bridge and an arch bridge,
a beam bred sprint delever, brandable bridge.
There are a lot of different kinds of bridges,
but they all serve the same thing.
So a bridge is a structure that's designed to be able to carry movable
loads from one side to another.
It needs to be able to traverse or span a distance,
whether it's caused by a body of water or another road that's beneath.
This is the guy who decides what kind of bridges to make.
My name is Dr. Nehemiah Maybree. I am a structural engineer and educator.
And what is a structural engineer?
Structural engineer is an engineer that specializes in designing
structures or any types of stable bodies.
That's able to resist loaves or weights of any kind.
So why are there so many different types of bridges.
Bridges are designed from the top down,
but they're built from the ground up. And so we,
as engineers began to think how much load or what type of weight this is
Brittany to carry, and how would this deck then transfer that weight,
whether it's a moving truck or a resting care pit or concrete
divider.
How do you decide what kind of bridge to build?
Right. So there's a couple of things we look at when we want to design a bridge.
So you look at skew angle,
you're going to look at stationy or work points.
You also going to look at what we call a typical section,
which is what is it gonna look like if once we slice this bridge in half,
what do we want that typical section to look like? And then from there,
once we get that,
it's a matter of calculating the loads that the various lists of girders or
various length of materials that are necessary.
We're going to also look at the material that we want to use to then be able to
produce that typical section that we desire.
There are primarily two main forces that each component each member of a bridge
is going to experience is either a tension force or a compression force.
Attention for us is basically a force that will attempt to try and stretch
the member or stretch the component of the bridge.
And a compression for us is a force that will attempt to shrink the member
or the component of the bridge.
And so those are the two main forces that any member of the bridge will have to
experience. Some members will have to experience both at the same time.
For instance, if you have a beam now,
a beam is a long member that is meant to span from one support to the other
support. In many typical cases,
the beams are supporting the loads transfer from the deck. Well,
in the middle of the span,
these beings are often bending or experiencing a
stresses or a force that causes a bend. Well, in this case,
you're going to have the bottom of the beam.
That's going to be tempted to be stretched. That is attention for us. However,
the top of the beam as it bends is to be experienced in a compression force
because at the top,
it's going to be shrinking an example of a component experiencing maybe just
compression would be the columns.
This is a member of a part of the substructure,
which is connected directly to the foundation as the loads from the beam.
Rest on the columns,
the columns are going to be experiencing compression more specifically,
axial compression along the lift of the column.
Another case where attention may be the only thing,
given a case of a suspicion bridge.
These are bridges where you see a draping cord or cable going from one support
to the other,
and then hanging from those raping cables are additional cables that are then
attached to the deck to hold up the deck. Well,
these particular cables are experiencing pure attention because it is
experiencing a forest that is stretching those cables.
So here's a bunch of different bridge types.
The suspension bridges,
they are typically supports or towers connected by a draping
cable. And from those draping cables on both sides of the bridge,
there are vertical cables that then connect to that draping cable down to the
deck. And the way that the deck is then resisted by those vertical cables.
And Tenten connected to the draping cables that then transfer the load to these
towers.
What's the best example of a suspension bridge.
The most recognizable example,
particularly in the United States is the golden gate bridge.
The golden gate bridge is that bright red,
beautiful landmark out West that has these two very strong draping
cables going from the North to the South tower. And from those cables,
they're typically made of steel wires wound and compacted together,
which make them very, very,
very strong intendant draping vertically from those main cables down to the
deck.
What's so great about this suspicion bridge is that it's in a region that is
known to experience earthquake being that they are supported by cables.
For the most part, there is the ability for bridges like this,
to be able to have some sort of gift and not be so stiff and be able to
move even at the ground shakes without severely damaged in itself.
The North and South ends of a suspension bridge,
particularly the golden gate bridge are referred to as peers.
And these peers act as the substructure,
which needs to resist those forces that is being applied to it by these
main cables.
And so these big peers need to be extremely reliable because they are
essentially resisting half of the bridges weight.
[Inaudible].
What's another type of bridge.
The similar or cousin I like to think of to the suspension bridge is a cable
Staybridge. And this case,
this is similar in that they are towers primary supports that then connect to
the ground. But instead of having two main draping cables,
the cables are then attached directly from those towers,
from those peers to the deck,
each side of the sort of acts as a counterweight to the other side.
And so this is not only helpful in the way that the bridge remains in
equilibrium,
but this is also something that many have used to their advantage throughout
construction of those bridges as well,
by coating things in place as things are being built.
What it allows you to do is use cables to then act as a resisting
force to the suspended or a hanging deck because the deck in
and of itself is not required to have anything beneath it.
Your cables are able to go much,
much longer than you could fabricate anything else to serve as a soup.
So cable stayed would be really useful for longer toll bridges.
Yes. So the Milan buy it up is actually the tallest bridge in the world.
Being that you have each peers that is about the height of the AFA tower itself.
And from it, you have your cables that are keeping the deck in place,
making it a very aesthetically appealing bridge,
but also using the counterweights of both sides to be able to have a much
longer span in between peers than you would with any other bridge type there's
only, what's so long, you can design a plank or a girder. And so,
because you don't want to have so many supports also when you're versing or
you're building a bridge across a large body of water,
the energy and the effort it takes to,
to drill piers or piles down below beneath the surface
of the water and to build these supports makes it more of an incentive to have
less support, right?
Because we want less supports we're then going to consider a bridge type that
can allow us to have longer spans,
hence the suspension bridges and even more.
So the cable state bridges becomes an attractive option.
Not to mention it just looks cool.
So that means some cable stayed. Bridges might have only one support. Right?
Exactly. So the Langkawi SkyBridge is a curved pedestrian bridge.
It's just beautiful. It has the aesthetic value right there.
It's an interesting design challenge.
When you look at how can we put this manmade structure in this place,
but yet at the same time preserve the natural beauty of that environment.
So it is then advantageous to then say,
how can we have the minimal model appears in this case,
even one pier positioned and act as a support for the entire bridge,
which is why this trust pier is singularly located and then attach the
cables eight cables to be exact that are necessary to support the deck and
various points thus providing the support needed to support the traffic.
Can you combine these different bridge types? Yes.
So the Brooklyn bridge is a good example about hybrid between a suspension
bridge, as well as a cable stayed bridge. So you have your very,
very large towers, your pillars,
your peers that have existed for a very,
very long time that had these drapes cables from one to the other,
from these drink cables, they're vertical cables that are attached to the deck,
as you would see in any other suspension bridge. But if you look very,
very closely, you will also see some cables. Aren't at a diagonal.
They're also attached from the deck directly to these tower peers,
which makes it more of a hybrid between your suspension bridge,
as well as you're able state state,
the cables of the Brooklyn bridge are comprised of 19 strands that are
then bundled together.
And then each of these are composed of about 278 wires per strand.
And together, they actually produce a much stronger tension resistance.
Then if you just had a single solid strands,
those towers on the Brooklyn bridge are stone towers as well using limestone,
granite and other rocks that have proven to be able to stand the test of time
because of their durability and strength and compression.
[Inaudible] what is our third bridge type.
Arch bridges are primarily resisting the load and axial compression along the
art within art bridges themselves.
You could have a spandrel art bridge where the deck is a buff, the arch,
or there are cases where the arch is elevated and the deck is actually through
the arts. And so we call that a through arch bridge,
particularly stone bridges stand the test of time because stones are a natural
material.
And so using a material that has already went through the years of weathering
countless years of re formation,
and really been able to remain what it is over millennia.
So I think that's one of the reasons why stone bridges and even art stone
bridges is able to stand the test of time because it's simply asking of the
material, what the material has already been doing for many, many,
many years when it's designed appropriately. And the geometry is nailed.
You can pretty much have a bridge that is.
Invisible. What's a good example of an ancient arch.
That's still standing today.
Conduct another example of a stone arch bridge. Here.
We have series of stone arcs that allow the force to be transferred actually
throughout the art, these smaller arches.
Then of course transfer the load to the bigger arches.
It takes advantage of the opportunity to break breaking up.
The spans says that so much isn't required of a single art.
It's also redistributing the load of law across the smart arches,
so that as they're transferred upon the bigger arches,
the larger artists can then act as peers that are space further out apart
giving greater space.
[Inaudible] what then is a trust bridge.
Trust is a structural type that is comprised of several different
elements. The triangle,
the shapes are necessary such that each element of the trust is experiencing
a pure attention or peer compression.
Can you give us an example? So the city.
Of Harbor bridge employees to trust in the staple of an art,
and it also is the type of art that we refer to as a through art grid.
So is that the deck is not above the art, but it's in line or belief.
The apex of the art,
there are also vertical stress that then connect from the trust art that
are to support the deck tension.
This aligns with the use of the elements within the trust as well,
which are also designed and put in place to be able to only experience purely
axial forces, whether it be in compression or intention.
Aren't trust bridges used by the military for rapid deployment.
Absolutely.
The Bailey Ridge is sort of a military bridge that is prefabricated prebuilt
away from the site that it is to be put in place to transfer vehicle or
pedestrian traffic.
It really came out of the need for military units to be able to quickly build a
bridge for it,
to be light enough for them to carry with them as they move from one place to
the other. And it's sort of like an erector set,
a piece-by-piece prefabricate it put together and can be constructed
without the use of heavy machinery without the use of a crane or any pile
drivers of any sort.
[Inaudible] what type of bridges this.
So I can deliver is a structure that is support it on one end,
where there is a fixed site or support whether beams or other
types of support members that are resisting the rotation of the deck.
And so can,
the LIBOR is incredibly important to make sure that the fixed in is strong
enough and that the flexing extended member has the ability to
resist the tension on the top and the compression on the bottom,
perhaps the longest Kendall LIBOR bridge has the Pontiac Quebec bridge there in
Quebec, Canada steel,
unlike concrete is extremely strong intention.
It can resist forces that attempt to stretch it.
And so while we are making beams that perhaps are going to experience
a lot of bending,
we want something that can resist the compression at the top and the tension
at the bottom, or vice versa, depending on how it's expected.
So how do you make a material that resists heavy loads?
We've gotten very sophisticated in how we are anticipating the types of lows
that these beams are going to experience.
And so instead of just simply putting steel inside of the concrete.
So as you had that reinforced composition,
there's another type that we call pre-stressed concrete.
We take the steel before we bring the concrete in and we stretched out the
steel. And while they're in that tension position,
we then pour the concrete around it and create a beam with the tension steel.
And after that concrete has hardened,
then we released the tension off of that steel,
such that now the steel wants to then retract back to its original position,
but because it now has concrete around it,
it is actually pre stressing before it experienced any load is already applying
a stress load on the concrete.
And so now you have a bowl where the concrete or the beam is going want to
naturally without any load on it, bow up a little bit.
And so that's a way to sort of anticipate the fact that when Lowe's go and we
put these beams in place,
the Lowe's are going to want to make the beam deflect downward.
But because we put what we call Canberra,
we put Canberra into this pre-stressed beam.
We sometimes are able to achieve no deflection at all at the beginning of
installation.
What other bridge types are there?
Well, we're talking about plank bridges, then those planks are acting as beams.
And so they have to resist what we call bending moment.
And so a bending moment is what causes these beams in this case to experience
both tension and compression compression, being at the top,
as it begins to bend intention, being at the bottom as it begins to deflect.
So you being bridge is the largest wooden footbridge in the world.
It has wares of a thousand wooden pillars that have been driven
throughout the water, along the length of the bridge.
It has approached bands that were originally made of stone or brick,
but had then also been replaced by wood over time.
The weathering and the deterioration of certain pillars have been
replaced with concrete. But nevertheless,
this is primarily an entirely constructed Woodbridge that offers
amazing views, their Miramar along the length of this bridge.
There are four wooden pavilions at equal distance.
I don't know you would call them maybe a check points along the length of the
bridge being that is so long.
[Inaudible].
So what about this bridge in a notion that Japan.
What type is this, this Ridge, there's another pure example of a bridge type.
You aren't separate members that you're connecting and transferring low with,
but it can almost be looked at as a frame in and of itself that put in place.
And you look at it and this, the money side right there,
like looking at the super steep incline and decline that it has when you're
approaching the bridge.
That site definitely it helps exaggerate the steepness of the gray. However,
it is a lot steeper than your typical Brit on it's a
vertical carb as we call it. It has about 5%, 6% slope,
which is quite the slope for any passenger or vehicle driver may
typically drive on, but is necessary because instead of being a moveable bridge,
they decided to make it high enough with enough vertical clearance,
such that to ships can then pass their Japan right underneath it,
without any needs of actuators or mechanical devices, to be able to, to move.
[Inaudible]. And then there are movable bridges.
Move where bridges are things that we see that are designed to be able to not
transfer it.
The low sturdy continuously using a deck that connects across the chasm.
But it's also designed by some mechanical powered devices to be able to
move into lift up such that the waterway that is traversing can allow the
passions of bolts or any other vessels that need to pass by.
It can then also be lower back in place so that the lows can continue to travel
across.
It. Let's hear an example. So the.
Somerset bridge is a very,
very short timber bridge to be able to cover a passageway
in Bermuda that connects Somerset to work Bermuda.
And it's a movable bridge as well.
This bridge doesn't need to be completely moved out of the way there aren't big
ship or water vessels that are passing through. In fact,
this mover bridge is operated by hand, unlike other movable bridges,
which may use hydraulics or other mechanical means it's just hand-crank
bridges that allows the deck to open up just perhaps two or three
feet, just wide enough for a mask of a small boat to be able to pass through.
What about a bigger example? Okay. Yeah.
Ah, okay. I got you. Gates hit millennium bridge.
This bridge is actually a pedestrian bridge,
not meant to transfer any vehicle traffic, but Walker's,
doggers cyclists are able to travel that curve outer semicircle of the bridge.
It's amazing because it has sort of that I look is referred to as the winking
eye, as a nickname, just incredible and incredible does Marvel,
particularly when it first went up,
it was one of the first of its kinds that we are ever seen like that instead of
actually moving and separating two components of the bridge,
it is saved in a way such that the semi-circles are able to rotate.
And when it is in an upright position,
it then creates enough vertical clearance for ships and sea vessels to then pass
underneath. And then it's simply rotate it back into it place.
What about this Saifai looking bridge.
It's pretty cool. Looks like a little roly-poly bridge.
And what's interesting about this bridge is that as in a lot of movable bridges,
this has several joints throughout and triangular sections such that it's able
to curl up upon itself with multiple bending locations throughout the length of
the bridge. So as it curls up using the power of hydraulics,
being a system that employs the pressure of fluids is able to then
add it size, be deployed very quickly, rolled up,
put back down again,
nice and neatly triangular segments fold on top of each other and then roll back
out just as easy as you would see a.
Is there one bridge that puts a bunch of these examples together,
the tower bridge.
This is another kind of hybrid bridge. It's a suspension bridge.
And then it's also a movable bridge in the middle,
on the outsides of the towers.
There are suspension cables vertically supporting the deck,
but then there is a walkway bridge at the top of the two towers beneath there is
a Drawbridge that lifts up allowing the passage of ships.
But what's interesting about the tower bridge is that there is also a walkway
bridge at the top,
which in and of itself acts as a connecting member between the two towers,
because the outsides of the towers are suspension bridges.
They are experiencing sort of a cooly force.
That's attempting to pull them apart. Therefore,
the walkway that is connected at the top, the acting as a connecting member,
that's experiencing tension itself,
keeping the top of the towers also aligned in place.
[Inaudible] what is the same about all these different bridges?
All of these different types of bridges are essentially doing the same thing
they're carrying low and they're transferring it to the ground.
They're just accomplishing that and slightly.
Different ways.
So how do you make sure a bridge stays up for a very long time.
Infrastructure that has been built years ago,
expiring for lack of a better word around the same time causes
decision-makers at the determine what will we replace entirely and what can we
afford to just simply repair.
It's not uncommon for bridges to be designed with what we call a 50 year design
life cycle bridges incorporate a lot of reliability
measures, which determine with a high reliability,
this bridge will be safe for this amount of time, say 50 years.
That doesn't mean that this bridge can no longer perform its function after that
design life. However, this is just the highest, uh,
interval confidence for which that structure can be designed.
You may see in our country, particularly may countries that had large,
massive infrastructure projects,
50 or so years ago now at a point where a lot of our heavily
used bridges and structures are requiring frequent maintenance.
There needs to be a more frequent inspection cycle.
There needs to be perhaps some modifications removal of the concrete that has
spalled off or deteriorated or crumble and replaced with something more durable,
such as weather protected steel, which we have or epoxy coated deck.
And so there are rehabilitation efforts that can just as well reduce or
restore the ability of the bridge, as opposed to just tearing it down.
Perhaps there may be cases where an engineer may go in and spec,
they analyze that,
look at how it may have deteriorated or fatigued over its life cycle.
And they won't recommend that it'd be torn down,
but they may recommend that it'd be posted and that instead of carrying a
certain amount of load, now,
it be determined that it can only carry a fraction of that load and continue to
then function safely for the public.
Restoring urban infrastructure is a huge issue because of the fact that the
users increase at such a higher rate.
And that's why in York allowing the bridges age of the bridges,
and as well as the levels of use that they experience require more frequent
intervals of repair maintenance inspection for the public.
We have a high number on a set,
the will number of either structurally deficient or functionally obsolete
bridges, which is why there has been widespread support for the restoration and
improvement of our nation's infrastructure.
So the choice is either preservation and repair or completely.
New construction.